toute cette semaine notre page et et
vous emmène à travers la touraine pour
des vacances
zen et décontractée nathanaël le maire
et david jouillat vous propose des
balades avec des moyens de déplacement
doux dans les airs sur l'eau sur terre
aujourd'hui pour commencer
nathanaël vous avez enfourchez votre
vélo pour une balade à chinon oui alors
le vélo connaît un fort engouement en
tout cas en terme de découverte
touristique depuis le développement de
la loi rend à vélo avec la loire à vélo
il ya des boucles et ici à chinon on a
même trouvé un un guide conférencier qui
fait ses ses visites sur des vélos des
vélos jaunes c'est des vélos aux
réformes et de la poste et ils sont
particulièrement bien adaptés à ce
mélange de visite de patrimoine mais
aussi de nature c'est le chinonais c'est
sur un vélo jaune un vélo réformes et de
la poste que s'effectue la visite du
jour une visite guidée en chinonais
ils sont made in france donc quoi l'été
mais des vitesses et tout ça c'est des
bons qualité donc son col roulé d'autres
membres mais on se fatigue jamais
bonjour jour là dont les ruelles
étroites du vieux chinon notre guide
conférencier à deux roues raconte
l'histoire de ces vieilles pierres
face à l'ancienne route des tours donc
et cette masse en ici sont à 100 est
aussi un siècle deuxième siècle et la
prononciation c ontre rues pavées bitume
chemin de terre et bords de vienne le
vélo jaune est vite adopté suppose que
les facteurs ont besoin quand même
de stabilité pour son toute la journée
sur ce vélo ont besoin de confort et de
stabilité
puis le panier devant est plutôt
pratique pour mettre les mettre les sacs
à dos et tout ça sur ces vélos réforme
et personne ne se prend trop au sérieux
ici pas de chrono pas de kilomètres mais
un ami qui vous invite à la découverte
de son pays de chinon son pays
d'adoption et sous tous ses aspects ça
c'est la ville sinon la liste finale et
voilà c'est michel evain donc je ne sais
pas combien les faits l'homme des
bellons fait même âge bien ça sur une
épopée héroïque qui retrouve un vrai
goût de balade
grâce à l'esprit de ce guide grand
voyageur qui a posé ses valises ici à
chinon effectivement il prend les comme
on a vu c'est pas les sentiers balisés
ont ni pour les vélos sur du macadam
avec les petits boss etc
c'est juste des vrais sentiers et il a
tout compris sur la vienne wakim baigne
six mois de l'année dans la vienne je
pensais connaître tous les endroits
il m'a emmené dans un endroit absolument
magique donc voilà ça c'est un regard
frais
voilà que les étrangers ont peut-être
une philosophie du vélo qui rejoint
finalement l'esprit de l'arabe les i je
vous propose maintenant de retrouver
notre guide conférencier martin donc qui
est originaire d'argentine qui a
beaucoup baroudé et à travers trouvez
vous tous vos voyages qu'est ce qui fait
que vous avez trouvé que chine on était
le bon endroit pour arriver avec vos
vélos donc notre arrivée ici j'ai
regretté la tour et il n'y a pas
longtemps mais j'ai fait mais après j'ai
découverte et tous ses côtés des chine
on a connu ça monte ans et c'est
beaucoup plus de nature c'est beaucoup
plus les balades bucoliques qui sont
beaucoup plus amusante donc j'ai
déménagé des tourelles si ce schéma
réussit ici pour faire les valises ici
qui sont plus que j'ai faits sont balade
bucolique données ont fait pique nique
on se promène tout de la journée qu'il a
fait pour ce faire ça alors expliquez
nous pourquoi ces vélos finalement vous
avez eu l'idée d'utiliser ces vélos qui
se sont révélés aujourd'hui
effectivement très pratique pour le
programme quand j'arrive ici j'ai fini
mon voyage et l'estonie j'arrive ici gpc
pas les pinceaux dans gm pour faire le
voyage en vélo donc quelqu'un a prêté en
vélo comme ça les facteurs cheylard et
ap parce qu'ils étaient non cave et fine
amène j'ai fait nous avons fait 300 1
350 kg matters est non seulement une
nouvelle comme ça i l était très
confortable et il y avait donné beaucoup
d intérêt ça les fleurs sens comme ça
chez découverte que s'étonner déchets
niel hockey effectivement ces vélos sont
assez sympathiques
demain nous poursuivons notre périple
dans le chinonais cette fois nous serons
à pied en randonnée sur les chemins sont
les pas de saint martin et basta beau
programme merci beaucoup nathanaël merci
à votre invité est à demain